and jose alvarez on the mound taking his
final warm-ups for alvarez
it's not
a complete novelty for him to start a
game this is the eighth time in his
career
that he has done so the last time was a
little over two years ago with the
phillies when he was the opener in a
game for them against the dodgers
there's a base hit by yelich
and yell it's on his way to second base
throw comes in late christian yelich
with a nine-game hit streak
and it's a one-out double here in the
first inning omar narvaez with two outs
and a runner at third
into center field that's a base hit and
the brewers do strike first here tonight
a two-out rbi single by omar narvaez
line drive to third chris bryant makes a
catch
sometimes you need a little help
and he got it the brewers get one here
come the giants in the bottom of the
first
so corbin burns singing one of the
cy young candidates in the national
league his 23rd start of the year yeah
just dealing 8-4 record 230 era and in
the month of august as he makes his
final start before we turn the calendar
into september 2-0 with a 167.
and a fastball at 99 from burns he
strikes out brandon belt
a shutdown inning after the brewers get
him on in the first all bundled up on a
cool night in san francisco
[Music]
they do want him to pitch his inning
with all the lefties that are lined up
here
bradley a little swinging butt that's a
tough play alvarez is going to throw and
branded belt luckily with the great
stretch kept his foot on the bag that's
when you'd like to have a six foot four
inch long armed left-handed first
baseman a runner at second base for
corbin burns see if burns can deliver
one here
there's burns a base head into left
field peterson winds it up he's gonna
head home no throw comes in from
dickerson
and corbin burns with his fourth rbi of
the season it's two to nothing milwaukee
that's a ground ball alvarez will go to
second crawford to first but not in time
not hit hard enough too much speed from
yelich so no double play they get the
force out at second
a bullpen knight alvarez got the call
and he's going to turn it over to jay
jackson
1-2 garcia strikes out swinging he went
with the fastball there's that jay
jackson smile
he got him brewers get a run they lead
two nothing a little shorter hair back
there we're used to seeing more flow
draping over the shoulders but
maybe he's a little more aerodynamic
towards the plate now swinging a miss he
got him with a slider
so brian is down two k's for burns
might have been too much velocity and
threw it too hard through the sink
and that one hits the outside edge 96
mile an hour gas
crawford
left standing there and it's three
consecutive strikeouts
at strike three call the fastball
so nice inning of relief from arlene
garcia middle of the third two-nothing
milwaukee
dickerson says i can hit it come on
into the corner garcia will dig it out
alex dickerson into second that's the
first hit for the giants it's a double
and that's a wake-up call
giant stug out will respond to this a
lead off double get him over situation
here for rossler
3-2 pitch and that's in there called
strike three
burns 97 miles an hour in the hall of
fame spot
one ball two strikes dickerson at second
and punts right through it snap throw in
a second back is dickerson that'll be a
strikeout
that's the 5k
got cold and flew like symptoms
and a book has been charged
yeah that's a big 90-foot mistake
that was a start stop
one and two
strike three the throw to third
and that's a double play
the tag by bryant the throw by posey
well you're already in score position
you're up there with a pitcher
and you're going to try and steal
base head to center field
it was the eighth pitch
that belt saw in this trip to the plate
and he drilled it
runner at first and a swing at a miss he
got him with a slider
corbin burns
strikes out chris bryant for the second
time
a double in a single
and crawford
in the air center field deepest part of
the ballpark and jackie bradley jr there
to make the play
headed to the wrong part of the park out
to triple's alley
so you saw the overlay that's a catch by
chris bryant who laid out
well
bryant's 6'5 yell at 6-3
and
bryant needed every bit
of that length to be able to spear this
one didn't have a lot of time he's
playing in on the grass
right in the sweet spot
the length of gloves there is a rule in
the rulebook about how long a glove can
be
there's another change impressive inning
for corbin burns three up three down
strikes out basler to end it he's
retired the last six now
one ball two strikes
and he got him a little foul tip into
the middle of narvaez for a strikeout
eighth punch out of the game for corbin
burns
2-2 and he got him a buzz bomb on the
outside corner
97 mile an hour fastball from burns and
a backwards k of buster posey
looking like a sigh young award winner
right here tonight two hits for the
giants tonight against corbin burns
belt's got one of them and he might have
another drives that one to right field
garcia leaps and he can't catch it
it's going to carry him back toward the
infield belt to second and brandon bell
is in scoring position to start the
seventh for the giants
bryant rips that one into left field
that's a base hit brandon belt to third
he's going to get the stop sign
so chris bryant is aboard that's back to
back and now
council will turn it over to his
excellent finishing bullpen box burger
coming on belted third bryant at first
nobody out
a bouncer and throw into right field
base hit
belt will score
bryant stops at second and the lead is
down to one
and ruff whistles out with the left
yelich is right there and the giants
strand two seventh picks of the abbett
brewers have him at the corners up two
to one eighth inning
and whis lines one to right that'll get
it done wade makes the play
tagging at third is narvaez he will
score and rhys
delivers with a sac fly and an rbi it's
three to one brewers
comes down to this two outs ninth inning
hater ready to fire and a swing and a
fly ball shallow right center it is
garcia who makes the catch to end the
ball game hater with the save
you